college kids love kamala but don't know
why
allah i don't even know where to go
after this
yeah they give kamala a five-star review
for what they haven't a clue
despite a recent survey saying nearly
half of americans disapprove of the vp's
performance young people applaud her
when asked by conservative news site
campus reform check it out i really like
her i think it's very um
inspiring
to see our first you know woman vice
president i do love having a woman
person of color democratic leader in
that position
and i think she's
a great representation i feel like
definitely it's amazing to have a woman
vice president and we're making
great headway with that and she's a
definite girl boss
it's person boss
anyway
anyway when asked why they love her much
like alicia silverstone in the 90s they
were clueless
can you name any specific
accomplishments that you're super proud
of
um besides her being the first on so
many different forums that would be my
first thing
off the top of my head i can't think of
many of them no honestly i don't really
keep up with politics on social media
i've seen that she does great posts so
yeah can you name any specific
accomplishments that she's had since
she's taken office
um no not any specific ones particularly
no what policies specifically do you
agree with
i don't really know
can you tell me some
maybe i don't maybe i don't know what
her policies are
maybe you can just cut that part out
she's destined for tv
i have to admit that's pretty funny how
funny let's ask the expert
what do you want to know
i want to give you i want to give you
the opportunity
oh she is adorable cat um is it fair to
ask college kids anything about the
world at all it's like trying to get
donuts from a bathtub i can't be a
hypocrite in 2013 i worked for campus
reform and at usc i made a video where i
walked around asking people if they
thought obama deserved his nobel peace
prize and why and i think we have that
yes we might i just feel like in general
being a good guy
it just is creating a lot more peace
and like mellow and not and so much
anxiety among the people i love obama
and i think that everything he's doing
everyone's just so hard on him but i
mean it's the second year
so
hey just a second i thought you were in
the video yes i was gonna say garth from
wayne other than the fact that i am not
it is true i am now far more attractive
than i was in 2013 which is good i can't
wait to see me when i'm 86 years old i'm
just gonna be so hot no one will even be
able to look at me
um but other than my
very much more attractiveness so hot now
um
not much has changed no i asked them all
do you think they were like yes
why i don't know like he's a good dude
and it's like it's not getting better
and it's sad because these are the same
people who will tell you that if you
disagree
you are a horrible person sexist racist
bigoted idiot yeah if you don't think
that these people are so great and so
wonderful but they don't even know why
other than they saw a meme
yeah you know what joey the hilarious
thing about this is their grasp of the
world is inversely proportional to their
arrogance about the world
see i i consolidated what you said into
something that made sense well i had to
fit in the part about how good-looking i
am oh yes
someone had to here's here's the problem
number one
out of the mouths of babes right like
she's like they were cute weren't they
maybe they're maybe they're in any
accomplishments you're challenging my
entire existence right now can we just
go into the shop i'm almost positive
that was in georgetown which i find
hilarious because all the videos now are
from georgetown they're all stupid and i
went to that school so i hit this true
but here's the problem with it
those people are 18. they also exist at
28 and 38 and 48 and 58 those aren't the
people electing our presidents every
every four years their parents are their
older siblings are there and people are
just as disconnected and just as tuned
out because in this country poverty
comes with a cell phone we are a an
amazing place right we have prosperity
on our down years we're we're mad
because we're buying a 3 000 square foot
house instead of a 4 000 square foot
house this is an amazing place to grow
up and live you can be stupid and in
college
and we all need to care more we all just
need to tune in more and hold people
accountable you know 20 years in a war
i'm not going to give that one up
anytime soon i apologize you got a
little bit of a personal rub i'll
explain later okay
dagon yes sir egg and dag and dag and
dagon digging i think people like
young people
they like to they claim that they like
to stand out
in a simple way like i'm going to dye my
hair blue i'm going to get a nose ring
like though that's like a a really brave
choice but when you see these things
it's actually they just want to blend
when it comes to ideas they don't want
to stand out at all it's a very
interesting contrast right they you can
tell they just want to say the right
thing right because take it from me if
you try to stand out like my entire 20s
i had a haircut like joey's
and um that you can't catch a a dude
if you stand out
yeah like that but i have something to
say for these girls yeah
or the college students they're super
smart
if somebody comes up to you with a
camera and a microphone
in college and says what do you think
about the first black female vice
president in history you're right and
they stick the microphone in your face
what are you going to say what you
better be she is wonder she's
wonderful
because you're they're sitting there
thinking she's amazing because if i say
anything negative i will never get a job
and i'll be labeled a racist bigot for
the rest of my adult life and then when
they ask the kid the women and the boys
they ask them
what is her accomplishment of course
they can't say anything because she
hadn't done anything right so they are
right on both counts you know what
the lady over there tom can't remember
her name
but uh she made a great point it's like
i'm making fun of these people all they
were doing was self-preservation that's
right they knew they were on camera can
i say the campus has been reformed greg
[Laughter]
i mean
when i was in college
girls did not wear summer dresses
they didn't wear these little how about
that little terry cloth number with the
you know well maybe they're not in
school right now well they're on campus
greg okay
you are really an old-fashioned person
should they be wearing like a like a uh
something out of a burlap bag
i'm saying on my campus that's the way
they look they dressed it down i love
the look i think and you know pairing
the terry cloth onesie with a pair of
roller skates i think it's a great look
all right all right all right
hey if you killed that many people you'd
be sweating too
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else